Wow and don't be a dick just don't be a
dick
is it on alright anyway ladies and
gentlemen we got another fat theme song
from Kyle quiz mundo on Rifkin with
Griffith thank you for listening once
again and this is a special movie
podcast version of the podcast and I
have on once again my favorite Lee
brother Bobby Lee Griffin it's Steve
Steve get it on it must be rapping Steve
Steve Lee and Bobby Lee you just do dude
one is bad wanna scare me what are you
doing
you can rap you tired you're too tired
to rap yeah what is your problem right
now dude put the music down your
attitude right now [ __ ] you dude with
your attitude right now Dave we asked
you to be a part of this group and now
you're having an attitude what are you
talking about you were like if I don't
get a Red Bull you're not gonna go no
how dare you
dude I filmed two podcasts yesterday
myself oh wow yeah and my patreon is
struggling
why are you gonna have him read zone
from me
it's it's in a different ya know
stratosphere oh they started before you
I know I know and I why'd you yeah what
are your feet wet and I talked to my
therapist about it yeah and I realize I
can't it's like apples and oranges right
he's got decades on me mm-hmm I just
started druthers I know I know it's just
my frustration of I'm trying to like at
least be self-sustainable to that's all
you might be that's all yeah yeah and so
it's just frustrating that like cuz I
spend a lot of time on my patreon yeah
we should just why am I even do it like
you know what you should spend time on
what brushing your teeth because when I
got in the car your breath was like
Chernobyl dude
well can I defend myself yeah yeah you
don't know I went to the dentist this is
Aaron Aaron and I went to the den okay
what'd they say I have a hole I have an
actual hole mm-hmm like uh like a well
okay do you vote on one of my teeth
right here and is it like do you want me
to show you pic is it holder does it
just go to the [ __ ] holding funk in it
is that what like it's like capturing
and it's staying in there I know this
you know how that there's nerves there
yeah the nerve is dead now all the
nerves gonna be doing if I don't go back
and get it pulled it's like um infection
wrong well you have to go do it he's on
antibiotics right now right no I ran out
oh yeah good night see can I say this so
it was I who the [ __ ] paid for it he
helped me help me out yeah
help me all right all right let's man
this is a horrible start my patreon
because has nothing to do with movies
sorry I'm gonna make it amends
okay make them sorry I'll be I'm just
gonna be I'm gonna be chill now this is
my problem self okay that's really I
just wanna I wanna help you I'm your
brother I love you okay yeah so I'm
sorry let's also talk about how he
doesn't have a Netflix account could we
talk about why this is a horrible start
these are the reasons why it's a
horrible start because all of these
things are like just individual problems
yeah this is a collective podcast we
tried on I just be talking about like
movie hey you're the one that brought
her Joe I know you act like we were like
hating Steve how's your teeth how's it
how's the hole there's a whole there's a
big hole yeah we're gonna fix that no no
don't worry
yeah the dentist said that um he has
such an infection that the nerves have
died and and now he has to be
antibiotics cuz he could just get like
some cancerous thing okay we're gonna
miss my character but what my question
to you is why didn't you brush before
like know me because then you have a
mouth in fact she kisses in American
society right I'm a I brush my teeth
okay if I use crest whitening whatever
the best stuff is out there are you
swear to god you do you floss and you
brought your DNA every day you didn't
ask me if I've lost twice a day yeah
once in the morning yeah in the shower
and then at night okay all right and so
I don't know I just have the position
it's the sugars maybe mm-hmm it's the
sugars yeah he's making his own shirts
no I like yeah yeah I like it too well
you need to take care of your health too
mr. yeah I have I have I have um blood
results back yes saying that I have high
blood pressure on the precipice of
diabetes I'm saying with the cut your
mouth yeah but when I open my mouth
flowers don't die that is literally the
first time I've ever air and laugh out
loud don't do that to me alright so
Robbie's killing here's another thing my
brother I know we're gonna go to is it
we're getting into movies almost please
no you said something before we even
started that I'm in in cell you are an
in cell why do you say that well first
of all let's clarify what it in cell is
it means involuntarily celibate only a
male could be an in cell it's dudes okay
right and I'll tell you who's not in and
so there's the terminology in this whole
community look there's a Chad okay which
is like the Brad Pitt crystal fille de
lis is it here's a she's a Chad he's a
good-looking boy and then there's the
beta
there's the betas with the beta you're a
beta I'm a beta I think we're all what's
a beta a beta isn't like you if you're
under a certain height
you're a beta if you look a certain way
you're a beta okay this says in cells
are members of an online subculture who
define themselves as unable to find a
romantic or sexual partner despite
desiring one a state did they describe
as in seldom self-identity in cells are
largely white and are almost exclusively
male heterosexuals Oh bro in the last 25
years right how many girlfriends have I
had
but either thing is you bypass the
system somehow you're like way more
feeling you know what you say find a
loophole in the matrix yeah you're
saying I'm an ugly person who shouldn't
get women I mean I cuz you're smarter
than pride no you're from you you found
you kind of
navigated around the system and found a
backdoor entrance way and you didn't
yeah because he's smart cuz when in the
90s he's like you know what when he was
working in the kitchen ember what you
gettin well you're working at last in
the the La Jolla Cove restaurant yeah
yeah he realized I'm I'm not gonna hit
girls this way you know what I'm gonna
I'm gonna go to the comedy store and
work the door and then I'm gonna do this
do this go on tour with Paulie that boom
boom boom and then he just it's like in
cells who like no but that's he's not
but that's totally off to the off the
beaten path what do you mean he's in
cells they feel like they have no way
nothing they can do nothing they can do
they can get women but also there's a
negative connotation to back in the
picture okay all right I'm first of all
let me tell you why you're not in sell
it off D yeah okay because I am you have
a girlfriend and you live as a matter of
oh it's just deal with you just for the
fact yes I'm five four or five five you
can't and you know f you know and it's
in the Asian community you know Noel
stuff yeah
you need to relook at you you know that
you then what am i alpha my or am i beta
if your exactly that means if since I'm
on then that qualifies me more as an
instant no it does it does what alpha
yeah
the oh no no no that's not true there
could be several alphas like not in a
pack
okay yeah okay okay I agree with you on
that I know I agree with you on that
right yeah I'm sorry alright yeah so
what you're telling me in in a wolf pack
you have one alpha male you're needing
the pack right so all the other dudes in
this pack these pack of wolves I got
[ __ ] insult him alright that's a
great analogy I like the wolf pack
analogy yeah I agree with you on that
okay why is it I'm gonna ask you this
then they all look up to Elliot Roger
the Santa Barbara killer
he was half-asian half-white because he
was he was not ugly but yet the insel
community looks up to they look up I'm
gonna stop you right there okay review
show we haven't mentioned one will we
will we will this is the ear oh I need
to get this off my chest get it off your
chest all right so here's the deal dude
when I was a young man in high school
and then when I graduated from high
school I had crushes on women and I
would hang out with them right and I
would hang out with them for months
mm-hmm I would never express myself yeah
he'd watch him sleep I watched like look
at their toes the truth is coming out so
you're a creep there's one there's one
girl named Tara black where while she
was sleeping at her toes there seemed
like that's my move that what it might
be not my move all right you know so
here's the deal okay but in all those
times where I hung out with this women
later in life they've I've talked to
them okay go how come you never made a
move
Yeah Yeah right I worked with the
guy who was a dwarf mm-hmm at a coffee
shop Oh cack in the early 90s yeah but
then he was not a [ __ ] he was always
with he but he had also you know a face
like they're alright well this had the
panic in during the panic and even he
had a face like this okay yeah oh sorry
sorry Aaron so so there was a so was
there was a storm Ryan uh-huh and he
always had women right and I walked up
to one day and I because of some at a
bar with this really hot a probably
regular-sized you know chip model
yes ridiculous oh yeah you know and I go
hey I used to talk like you
I thought he how do you get one right
yeah and he goes he looks at me run
there as he goes Bobby I've never seen
you try oh it goes I go up to bat a
hundred times I might strike out 99
times but I always hit one mmm right
that taught me that it's a numbers game
numbers game it's not there was
something inside me that had this fear
of rejection right but it has nothing to
do with my look because once I figured
it out that I'm gonna go and just start
you know I mean hitting on chicks mm-hm
and and not take it personally when I
can't get them yeah that prepared you
for Hollywood because that's how that's
the audition process the audition
process and Holly yeah right right so
I'm betting in South what you guys are
missing the point
oh my gosh it doesn't matter what you do
how far you go on your career if you
want to like they label it look looks
maxing you know like doing you know
whatever to make yourself look better
most women they won't admit it but
they're ultimately like all going after
like the top 20% you know that's not
24/7 true at all I'll tell you why yeah
they want they would never admit it but
their ultimate they ultimately want like
the Brad Pitt like no they don't want
the good-looking go they don't know they
don't dude oh how they kind of just say
something really just listen to later
what I'm saying okay is is that a lot of
women respond to maybe that is some
women yes some women respond
- when a young when they're young they
go you know they always say I'm looking
for someone funny but then when you meet
their boyfriends are the most unfunny
asleep at all right which one of his
packs is funny on the signature as young
as a young woman maybe that is in the
beginning thing you get crushes on
whatever but later in life you room
women realize oh I need stability I
don't want somebody to be loyal right
okay okay I agree with you yeah yeah
yeah we've just maximized our strengths
yeah but that doesn't make you a Chad
though either you're listening to these
in cells definitions to that Oxford
Dictionary function isn't reconfigure a
ting like stop listening to the air it's
not right you're telling me these guys
that are doing these podcasts are like
they're just like bottom they're like
just about to either kill themselves or
like they've gave up online no they oh
they also hate women no way that it's
very well they hate what makes you think
there's hatred involved they're okay
with it a lot of them are okay with it
whatever they like Chris Delia's
personality inside elliot rodger you
would have been knee-deep in it mmm-hmm
it's his his insides and his mind was
broke good dwarf the he knew you put dad
guys personality in like you know yeah
Eddie shall I put like delious
personality and to like a regular like
Bobby no like a regular looking short
then he'd be working at UPS here's a big
like kalila right kalila yeah back in
her early 20s she goes I blew the
ugliest dude and I couldn't believe her
yeah right and then she showed me a
photo of this dude who's one of the
ugliest dudes I've ever seen my life and
you totally got why she was into you at
that point right that was the point you
like Oh
who like hideous guys no but what I'm
saying to you is this is that here's an
eye you know I have low self-esteem I
really do like last night you know you
know on the the sitcom last night I was
watching it at the store mmm-hmm they
had it on right - sitcom on ABC I'm on
right which is called what's playing a
splitting up together on ABC and I was
watching I'm like no FATA you know I
mean I like I I have real like poor
self-image right amber does but here's a
fact I'm gonna show you a fact yeah
every TV show I've ever been in I test
the highest what stuff for the one with
the monkey the animal animal practice
the monkey be here yeah you didn't even
watch that the monkey had a bigger
trailer
no I feel Bobby was no one watched my
show I was I wanted to because I was
even saying press we got to wrap it up
because Bob's the last up though it's
showing right you know animal practice
from five years ago
oh that was the one that they canceled
because that's all they had a commercial
but my point anyway watching hey I just
know that when I test for things and and
just a focus group yeah they go oh he's
cute we like him yes there's something
about me that people hobby you're right
you're likeable is why he doesn't have
the in cell quality because he is one of
the most likable people that you want to
be around even though he's such a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know what I mean he
has a thing about him in sales it
doesn't matter what you do right that's
one that's exactly it
no just the fact that we're under a
certain height
say something about him guys anyway
welcome no you have been don't beg you
know as you know we last time we talked
about my Shyamalan movies we talked
about Star Wars we got a lot of love for
it and I thought here that suddenly we
got to continue to do so one of the
things that we all love the three of us
is we love scary movies
oh yeah scary movies one of them our
favorite favorite favorite genre and you
know if I think about some of the top 10
scariest movies I've ever seen but now
do you guys think this should be in like
categories because you have like gory
then you have like yeah that's a logic
demon possession the demon I don't know
if they I don't know if Oscar movies go
into the same category seen all of it
here's the thing I'm not that scared of
slash I'm like a crazy person man I know
what like Jason huh what do you what do
you like what why it's a slow burn
yes he does psychological he'll sit
there for the surprise at the end
yeah like hereditary yeah yeah he loves
that movie for some reason because it it
gives you clues and it slowly builds up
and at the end it's like this reveal no
let's see you know also he likes movies
that are based in something that this
could possibly happen because it's movie
land and people that's a good yeah
that's a good point yeah no you don't
you can interrupt but it's fine in sales
good interrupt yeah yeah I think I got
you got me riled up with the enzyme go
ahead but the thing is is that it the
movie her editor was scary to me because
it wasn't necessarily the supernatural
or the paranormal stuff it was the
dysfunction of the family I told that
really kind of deterioration is that the
right word yes yes oh yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah that really horrified
right well and then with with also with
the King payment and the paranormal
stuff aren't added on top of it and also
just the just the the the images will
see when you have a movie character when
you have this what's-her-name in the
star what was her name putting Collette
with Toni Collette great performance
right so when you can follow Toni
Collette and the thing that you makes it
scary is that you we can see what's
happening but the people around her
don't see and she's coming across as
crazy and you're trying to root for her
like you know prove it prove it prove it
and all these things keep happening
that's what you need that's what you
need a there's not a lot of jump scares
right now and what I loved about ya know
the way aster directed it he would do a
wide shot and you don't know exactly
what you're looking at
yeah but you and they would sometimes
you'll see something yeah or your mind
will see something he just didn't he um
he just directed it in a way where it
was like it was understated for sure
yeah yeah yeah yeah performances were
great performance trip I tell you what
else I like editorial I like the fact
that they used this mysterious sigil
like this the symbolism in it and I love
that you know how like there is that
symbol of the deparment symbol like on
that pole before yeah I love that how
they reveal that in certain spots of the
movie that the burn of it just the
feeling of it I just thought it was so
horrifying but I think a movie like that
too that I liked it too is at the end
when you had this big reveal then in
your mind you kind of make the sequel's
in your head yeah that's when it's a
good movie yeah when you could be like
oh god I wonder what happened oh with a
cult yeah you're like oh yeah this guy's
gonna be the demon king and yes goes on
and on and on and on and on I mean I
like those kind of like why it didn't
Gabriel Bernal leave the family yes
whenever there's always one I know no no
there's always one dude that you're
going you could leave you get out of
there get out of there so I don't know
is when did they have time did the cult
members like to get the the
grandmother's body up into the Attic
like when did that all they could have
done it in any time today at work the
kids rats cry
yeah they're part it's just I mean I
don't I mean it was good I saw it on a
plane and and I enjoyed it the whole
time but it's more of those movies that
I wasn't necessarily like frightened by
I wasn't it wasn't like I started the
theater right I saw it in a theater and
um and also you would see the Performing
right I saw it in the theater as well
yeah yeah yes I performing and I was in
Seattle with kalila and we're in the
theater watching yet and somehow because
it was so dark in the theater and then
you know the kalila I almost killed the
two couple of tell the story tell the
story so toward the end of the movie
like there was a scene where 20
Colette's body is in the corner of
ceiling right just like I didn't see
that in the theater what it's it's when
the the the the the boy the sons in the
dark room right no this is like when
this is when like the Sun is coming
downstairs and he and he sees there's a
scene before that where you you have to
really look we're in the in the boys
room she's slowly like on this side yeah
yeah that's why I didn't see that I
didn't see that part all that yeah so
there's - there's different moments of
that within the maybe away I don't know
which part that is it scared my eyes
when I screamed when I thought why does
all I was with cloth and I was looking
at the screen I what happened in the
theater the theater and the couple ahead
of me huh turn around and there go go at
this oh it reminds me of the master
let's not get back to don't get back at
that red zone again so that I screamed
again later
right there was another part when they
opened the door and there was a there
was like a a silhouette of a man sitting
standing in the door I want to know who
that was I'm think that was King payment
soul or what about to do the
transformation maybe I don't know
by the way you know it makes me angry
right now what this would be like we're
at a comedy and I'm laughing and someone
turns around and goes Shh right are you
[ __ ] kidding yeah yeah we had a scary
move I know I know there's some scary
[ __ ] just happened and I'm a squeeze
that's why I'm here right I'm here to
get [ __ ] stimulated by this like
you're on a roller coaster
you're like someone's out to yourself
yeah yeah I agree with you guys yeah and
I want to know I want to I want to tell
people what movie theater it was mm-hmm
and I want someone I need to find this
couple that didn't know what you'll
never find them yeah you know you'll
never find them
Bellevue Washington no come we're the
parlor live that movie theater would the
parlor library great great great
everything love great yeah I love that
great gig Yeah right
uh-huh so then I screamed again I think
the second time just to see right and
they did it again they turned around it
goes you guys have your mind someone who
said something but then once I saw
kalila lose it she turned into the lady
from the garage yes you try to pull up
her hair was over her face like this in
the dark staring at them it was like you
know I'm like you when I pop my head
like this yeah so you're gonna brawl
with another couple so the lights came
on the movie the credits go up mm-hmm
everyone leaves the theater mm-hmm but
the two they don't leave oh they wanted
to stand on no they they wanted us to
leave first or you were like oh I guess
what what let's not leave no I leave
when you leave oh you want it if I leave
when you leave to the point where they
start again and then as soon as the
house lights went on uh-huh and they
turned around
kalila and I bawled were their fingers
[ __ ] yeah oh you [ __ ] you crazy
dude dude I'll tell you right okay so if
you're up here in Bellevue and Tommy Lee
and his girlfriend cursed at you bro
please email me at Eric and Erin I'll
pull them a [ __ ]
would they look like by the way Oh
wonder what was I don't want to say
Indian please don't even like you could
you know because other one was because
if it was like Latino or something so
they were minority so people died yeah
so but that so now they are walking out
of theater huh
you know how that's it's three stories
up yeah they keep the escalators down
mm-hmm we're screaming at them like
we're right behind them and that's good
bad [ __ ] you hear me I'm a holy kalila
but they didn't respond bad right what
the best was people were coming up just
because I was about to prepare uh-huh
right so people were coming up the
escalator the street bro oh god I feel
so good what was your response
no the East or not they started now
yelling for security security
I go security are gonna help you know
you know I had a moment like that when I
was watching Schindler's List what yes
watching Schindler's List okay and that
movie is heavy it's a great movie you
hate you hate you just hate people in
this movies this Oh like a little older
couple sitting in front of me and they
this is one of these like one of these
moments in the movie where you're like
horrified that this is something that
actually happened yeah and these people
start talking man in a theater in the
theater they're kind of talking that has
nothing to do with the movie either
yeah not even like they were going like
this is horrible it was like some kind
of conversation and I was like shut up
you did that yeah because it was like it
was witnessing a history you know you
white people
yeah that's betta behavior behavior what
watch it alright hereditary was a
scary-movie no I want to say another
story right I saw movie right yeah how
dare you yeah which made me angry
you're the one with your analysis with
Aron Kader okay you know Aron Kader
right called taegeukgi was a great movie
movie right basically what the movie
just real quickly is about is it starts
off with an old man getting a call
saying that we found something so this
old man goes to this site like it's like
a renovation bro what do you call it
when they like discover something
excavation excavation site excavation
site right
and um they see the skeletons of a man
of a man holding a pencil or pen uh-huh
and he'd this old man no that's his
brother mm-hmm and it goes back to the
Korean War and the older brother so it's
like his older brother protected him but
then they threw this whole but they
split it out yeah he always appeared to
be in the war so he can protect his
younger brother aren't you telling no
story right up to that bride all right
and it resonated so strong cause I was
thinking about my brother you know and I
literally started crying and then I
walked her to the theater and there was
a alleyway they go Erin I need a second
and I went to the alleyway and I leaned
against the wall right and I started
crying right and then Aron Kader clans
next to me sits down he goes white
crying oh my god I've been near okay now
you're sitting yeah don't do that whole
bit
no I know what you're talking about yeah
I I have to go to movies with people
that are had the same sensibility yeah
like if like if I'm crying in a movie
like I saw st. Vincent with Dean Del Ray
st. Vincent don't worry God the end of
this movie when the little boy goes over
to his mom yeah and he's about to say
some tender [ __ ] I was in the movie I
was gonna do this to me right now I was
like oh [ __ ] dude and then like you know
I was doing it yeah
Dean sobbing - and I was like this is my
brother for life that's the thing you
got a brother for that and then we
last about it at the end of the movie
because we were like two grown-ass man
and therefore I need that yeah when I go
to a movie and so what I'm saying is
when I go to a scary movie I need that
too I need like like Bobby and I would
you go see this [ __ ] dumbass movie
with a nun in it okay it's nothing none
it's in the same genre with you yes do
we have a demon movie where they were it
was like they were it was an exorcism of
emily rose no it was something like that
but it was like they went to Europe and
and they were doing an exorcism and at
that point in the movie Bobby and I were
so scared he had his shoes off all he
did he went like this to me we gotta get
out of here we gotta get out of here
yeah you know I think I remember that
yeah what I'm saying is I that's the
kind of connection you have and you go
see a rock it was stigmata
stigma on stigmata no no not it was a
stigma it was something like that
alright alright no one else don't thrown
another [ __ ] movie yeah please I know
the hole it's like the guessing yeah
yeah yeah you know but what I'm saying
is like so for me demon movies like if I
ever met love them dude okay I'll tell
you one of the scariest movies I ever
saw it wasn't just because the movie was
scary it was it's a particular time is
when I saw I saw a double feature of the
omen 1 and 2 I remember when I got home
cuz I was with you I was with a group of
people where I had to pretend like I
wasn't scared but devil [ __ ] yeah that's
when a Damien's that like a teenager
scariest part of that when he's with the
teacher and he answers all the history
questions they kept like so I got home I
got home my mom's movie the pictures
anything revealed when he realizes he's
the answer mom yeah just that one time
right yeah yes to two fat black people
my mom is a very slim well I never
oh my god the fat people okay because
your family is the Asian Nutty Professor
over there yeah if you had a baby right
if you had a baby no just listen to me
if you had a baby right man you saw on
the skull not 666 but just two sixes
what would you do I would drown that
[ __ ] in a tub oh yeah maybe I'd
be enough yeah two sixes on the baby's
head there's got to be another six
someplace you think so I would look at
once x16 well what but that would be
weird to them that would be weird why
you're perfect six am i right I would be
like right it's almost like the devil
got tired
right I mean right you know it's like
you don't know I just realized you know
I know why movies the movies are more
scarier but that we didn't even mention
about hereditary it's the score I mean
that is a good one
cuz hereditary in the old school yeah
that's really well you know another
thing it's the music that scares me but
in that movie this is this always scares
me too is when it's full speed running
that always scares me what do you mean
when the monster is full speed running
after people scares me because I'm like
like the zombie and in this in
hereditary Collette when she was
possessed was she running to she was
running the [ __ ] after her kid which is
inverted on the going later supernatural
at that point in the movie you're okay
with supernatural but I'm gonna give you
an example of a movie that has no
supernatural [ __ ] in it but it scared
the [ __ ] out what the original when a
stranger calls have you guys ever seen
that no okay when a stranger calls it's
about a girl who's babysitting okay and
the kids are upstairs yeah she keeps
getting a phone call a prank call she
thinks that someone's going like this
after you checked the children that was
a long time ago right yes and they made
a remake recent right but this is the
old version in a whole movie so she's
calling the police
she's like you know what's going on
finally cuz it's getting creepy then the
police call her and they're like get out
of the house that calls coming from
upstairs you know that's the kind of
[ __ ] did I go [ __ ] here's another one
like that cuz that could really happen
here's another one did you guys see the
boy yeah okay the boy is like it's a
doll it's like this doll yeah the whole
movie you think that you're moving and
doing all this [ __ ] yeah turns out I'm
reveal this is spoiler alert yeah turns
out that this family the the they're
there they're disturbed kid who's an
adult now is living in the walls and
what he's doing is he's coming out and
moving the doll but he's Eliza live
that's no no no what I'm saying is you
think it's the doll yeah but is he alive
yes he's not a ghost
no dude how's that scary because a real
dude is it imagine it's like in your
house do you realize there was some old
man or something get on your walls
that's what's up right if my brother and
I are living together mm-hmm and he
comes home with a doll okay what right
off the bat but they made it out like
this doll was possessed
exactly no damn listen listen okay my
brother goes I got this at the haunted
Museum mm-hmm they had a sale okay
you're going closing down okay okay and
the dolls moving around all right
and my brother I'll just move right and
then two days later our cousin Andy is
in the wall moving it yeah then we'd be
like relieved no no no no it's Andy no
no but this problem is any what are you
doing and another thing in them but they
wouldn't you wouldn't be like that
because you would be like what the [ __ ]
this family made this woman believe that
this doll was possessed but they knew
that their kid was see they they were
leaving her there to die
they knew the guy was gonna kill her
they knew it they this is their way of
appeasing their their their crazy kid
anyway I'm saying there was no
supernatural in that movie so when
you've given up here's another one when
you find out in the end that it could
actually happen that kind of shift
scares me to shovel I'm over the visitor
visit this is right right right right
will you find out later that it's not
you right right grandparents yeah that
was scary
no that was scary but then what I knew
that but the scene that sticks out is
when the grandmothers all
if I look back on scary movies of all
time that I really enjoyed I love the
first Pet Cemetery I was just thinking
that Eric because of Zelda member the
the sister I never thought I never saw
him oh my god character named Zelda oh
it's so Seb little white kids I'm out if
they're double dutching or anything yeah
yeah that's good I never saw even the
Disney movies like Little Mermaid I
never scared I know why would he bring
that up while talking about pets so
obvious if he could know because Micah's
kalila my girlfriend was shocked that I
haven't seen is that shot is shocking
have you ever never said a little many
of those yeah this is why you go it's
what you guys had a weird childhood but
the Beauty and the Beast
what were your where's your father make
you watch you you watch the news no fun
movies nothing no my dad doesn't he's an
okay guy he doesn't know music you guys
didn't even have like well my dad had a
stroke
uh-huh you might had a stroke right we
don't have to take it there oh just give
it
okay all right go here and this is how
weird my dad is get a stroke is he an
insult my dad actually is why I mean
just for the fact the way he learns
five-foot-two I could okay yeah is from
here on out yeah I don't want to do in
cells or chats okay no betas no bay
that's none of your little turn right
it's gonna it's gonna hit up I know I
know and I'm with I know I know
yeah I'm gonna snack let's go back to
the story I've been interviewed ammeter
stroke my Deniz stroke and and he had
never heard music in his life well his
first stroke he has had several strokes
we
it's the major one the major I remember
when I heard music I listened he
obviously he's been in a mall he's been
in an elevator
yeah but he doesn't know that's the
Beatles or that's you know he was only
he doesn't know why the way this
explains so much so so so my mom was
like listening to Eric Clapton was it on
tears in heaven yeah and she put the
headphones in my dad's here and he you
know he's paralyzed right
he had a stroke and he heard music for
the first real Wow and he started crying
was I wasn't there I wasn't there and he
goes how beautiful oh yeah so he doesn't
watch movies or anything like that yeah
she's never seen anywhere just made me
so sad right now yeah why'd you do that
he watches mom he watches on the
splitting up together he doesn't
understand it yeah he doesn't go did his
beautiful he just once he just sees that
I'm working and it makes him proud
that's good yeah but you but what I'm
saying is how can you I don't understand
how you've never wanted to see Aladdin
or little what Lion King because what
happened I'll tell you what when those
happen I don't understand because when
those movies came out I was poor okay
when did they come out they came out
like the 90s so in the 90s ah I
graduated high school 1990
Lamarque all and then I was struggling
right because my parents went bankrupt
mm-hmm so I was living in San Diego just
like after the riots and they had like a
store before okay before this right the
right right the riots when it pertain
because I was telling kalila why I
hadn't seen it and then so when these
Disney movies are coming out as a young
male uh-huh you don't look at a Disney
photo of a billboard and go oh with the
little money I have I'm gonna botch I
got you Jurassic Park either then no we
had those I saw because I those that's
you can't put
Jurassic Park in the same as at the
particular time they were that it was
large like that that type of cartoon
work yeah but still the first time it
had been like yeah but still like it's
Spielberg it's live action no yes so you
know
to me in my early 20s as a man looking
at these now I their masterpieces I know
because even the things that I did catch
up with like I saw the incredible Toy
Story all those computer animation
movies I watched a ma I love them I
loved wall-e yeah I saw that in the
movie theater yeah I seen wall-e I think
but that was when I was starting to make
money right I can watch different things
one movie that stands out as the
number-one horror scariest the Exorcist
the exercise what no no I don't know I
think I've seen so many better movies I
think at the time that was really scary
but by the way Exorcist 3 to me had the
most scariest moment Exorcist 3 is a
[ __ ] masterpiece wait a minute dude
you're saying Exorcist 3 is better than
the original okay I'm gonna say this I'm
gonna say this okay all right I want to
say this all right
you've never seen Exorcist eree yeah I
have what was it about that's when the
it's not a mental asylum and there's
there's another character in there and
then it's like you know like and then
the father Karras like is like still
possessed in them and then there's
another priest that tries to like the
interviews okay I mean there's like an
investigator like investigates to figure
out what's going yeah well here's the
thing that that moment that moment in
the movie was there in that long shot of
the hallway yeah and the music turns off
that was like a 35 second where I I had
to take a moment there's also a scene
with the older like in the senior
citizens are in that room and then that
one lady for an odd reason sighs she's
don't know crawling like a spider
because I'll tell you why the original
act if you see it the original Exorcist
again it doesn't stand out it doesn't
stand through time it's just because of
technology like you know it's like the
real but it's the voices it's sighs okay
you listen my brother has a point all
rights this is yeah you have to you have
to sometimes put films into context of
the era right so
people go like I one of my favorite
bands growing up was the Velvet
Underground and when the Velvet
Underground put out their first album
only 500 people bought it right yeah but
through time right it influenced so many
other people to start a band right it
kind of created the alternative movement
right it's just like it's a masterpiece
that album but in its time it didn't do
what you know yeah right so sometimes
you have to put things into context and
what it means to you I just saw recently
and I got things in it because I've seen
it a hundred times but then I watched it
alone and I'd like studied it and there
was things in it that I didn't catch
like all those other times like for
instance like you know the father at the
beginning like they're in the Middle
East like Iraq wherever and then there's
that artifact of the the the reptilian
or the demon yeah and then I I didn't
realize that that throughout the movie
at the end it ends up in like Linda
Blair's like under her bed like like
weird things like that I never caught
and I'm like whoa that's a tradition and
not only that at the very end of the
final exorcism when she screams out you
know they're you know before the father
enters the home yeah she's actually
because she knows it's a demon and it
knows it's it already knew the priests
name that was that the main priests name
so there's like little subtle things
that I realized wow that's really scary
I just I could think of like some other
movies I enjoyed more I thought I
thought like the first ring I just that
really got to me even some of the
slasher movies like therefore the Chucky
the first one about the demonic it's
like you're how the demon realm knows
certain facts like the demon realm like
that the devil knows like your mother's
in here would you like to give her a
mess like demon movies yeah I also if
you see the documentaries on I watch the
documentaries on the exorcism on YouTube
what the Exorcist Exorcist yeah and it
shows the original documentaries about
people going to the theater and they had
to have medical teams there yeah dude
half the audience would pass out riot
people would vomit people would lead
wait didn't get out of the theater I
heard a story about Paul Mooney and
Pryor
- it was invited to a white party mm-hmm
right and then after the part of the
Dyke there's a screening of this movie
right and they didn't know what the
movie was and then it was the Exorcist
and Pryor and Paul Mooney try to escape
the theater I give it halfway dreaming
imagine if you get invited to a movie
you don't know what it is yeah it turns
out to be some frightening [ __ ] yeah I
think you have to prepare yourself to
where you go into a movie I don't want
to just be surprised by a movie dude
that I I think it's one of the best okay
I'm not saying it's the best it's up top
three to me at least yeah dude what
other movies name one or nameless for
you when you sit the ring not not the
Japanese wearing gold the Ahmet no the
American version version yeah we saw
that with mom the ring where she comes
out of the TI yeah yeah hair honestly
you know what's good slow burn funny
that it's at the tape yeah was scary to
me yeah yeah yeah really scared the [ __ ]
I got so you're putting that up against
the Exorcist what it was it's not a
competent to find out I mean I just
again if I guess I had to put myself I
never was an exorcist person like it
just I just didn't you know the head
spinning and if people were making so
many jokes about it you guys got me in a
corner and I was forced to talk about it
right in you know but I I like I say I
think Pet Sematary is one of the scary
ones - oh man I'm gonna watch it tonight
I know it's not pet somebody to watch
them you know what's infuriating they're
remaking that's him they're redoing it
yeah I don't know why do they make
remakes of already classic movies I
don't know I don't know why they've done
it name a few
did any of the like what about one a
series they did it with oh yeah I remade
Oh me I didn't like the new omen when
that little kid is holding the
president's hand at the enemy turns
around he looks good in the first was
like Flatliners yeah yeah why they long
oh yeah yeah well that's what Julia
Julia Robert Julia right after the day
yeah and Kiefer Sutherland
would you remove that yeah I can't I
don't even know there's like what about
the shining no no yes shiny it's a good
movie but I long had that it's a scary
movie just the shots the hallway shots
the way they do just just the whole
thing of him singing that bar right yeah
and then those photos of like back in
the day and he's in the photo
I know oh you just have whatever just
what he was like in the door yeah yeah
yeah you know like claustrophobic just
the shots of the hallways of memory he's
like on his little like toy thing like
like going through the hallways like you
felt like really like well that's just
like in the omen when he was riding a
tricycle and the mom was trying to do a
knock her off the ledge you just know
[ __ ] is happening yeah I don't know I
just I mean I haven't seen a really good
like but that's interesting those are I
didn't mean to cut you off but the
movies I like I think are from the 70
something about the 70s what's another
one well the the Shining's from the 70s
right he liked to take a bladder I love
Jake dude Jacob's Ladder was great know
so I guess my your taste your do you get
scared though it's a psychological you
like he likes jump scares yeah you look
like illogical yeah you like that
I like the cycle I like everything demon
[ __ ] is scary to me I do like a little
I like any time something's happening
that's not supposed to be happening you
know so anytime somebody's crawling on
the wall or like ya see somebody making
like a weird what about this the
slashers like Halloween or vampire I
love vampire [ __ ] but that's not really
scary anymore they've turned it into
like a tomorrow let's think about this
in all these movies in all of them they
don't make any why do people behave the
way they do in them so at the end of the
day when you're watching a scary movie
either give us an example what'd he tell
you Oh none in every situation a recent
one than none this is the one I just I
didn't see the nun okay somebody Alma
I'm a priest right so
he says yes you have to do some
investigating in an old Catholic Church
right where a nun was hanged herself
right yeah and I would be like no yeah
no no how about this though when they
first got to the cemetery did the
monastery and then he go down to where
the body is and the guy says I didn't
leave the body like that the body was
laying in a depression
that's the moment okay this is evidence
yeah ended it right there why can't
everyone other like that
yeah well explain I since I haven't seen
the movie explain what the movies about
Exorcist if I'm sorry after I take my
daughter to the best doctors in the
world and I put her in that room and
it's [ __ ] like I'll be the resident
in there how cold it is right and I'm
breathing and there's like you know like
I'm in the snow right and my daughter's
doing some freaky [ __ ] well what's your
face what I'm saying what's your okay no
it's your daughter that's family would
you leave
no it's family and car I did you would
not do that yes I did the doctor thing
already
you might lock her up and then you leave
too like well you know you go I don't
know if I'd be I would go get the priest
or I'd be outside and be like my
daughter's inside there cuz that's not
even your daughter anymore it's okay
there's one thing I forgot I'm
remembering you know another thing why I
love The Exorcist there's the thing I
didn't realize before until like
recently is the whole time you know how
she'll strap down yeah she was able to
walk around that room so that scared the
hell out of me like she was like it was
deceitful in a certain way like oh she
was you don't even say it was she was
tricky this demon was what I noticed
about Steve this what she likes the
filmmaking of it like I think he likes
that scary filmmaking tricks and
otherwise and I get yeah I get that yeah
it's like I guess I'm more understanding
like I want it to look real and so it's
like I just do you a story to be so
believable like well you're like I get
like I do like people to act in a
certain way that even if they act right
does monsters still gonna get them I
like that but when they're do is [ __ ]
worse like Leigh Whannell school ever
girls falling or it's like you say why
used to like all the Friday the 13th
what's one person is killed at the camp
camp is over okay yeah happiest oh yeah
yeah okay you going home okay
it's over you told you cannot
announcement hi this is camp director
this is Cape direktor Griffin someone
has been murdered yeah right we've
called all your parents you're going
home okay I'll give you something I'll
put something out there that combats
that what about in the movie the
original Evil Dead you can't just leave
that cabin area because the dim mean the
demons yeah but I'm offered up very
early remember the bridge is right now
the Evil Dead the first Evil Dead
somebody calls me all right there's no
Wi-Fi all your santino calls me a me and
five people are gonna go into the cabin
yeah woods yeah oh hey have fun fun if
I'm not back in a few days
no I'm not going oh you're not a woodsy
person oh no you would go into the woods
to a cabin five other people yeah I
don't know happen it just do it you
would you would do that I go look
considering considering let's say we go
to the care we go to this thing day one
you would do at the podcast I'm saying
do day one
kalila disappears day one we're not
we're we're going to get the authorities
no I don't believe it dad and even if
they caught off the road off the road
the demons are in the forest yeah I will
you can't leave that you cannot leave
this gets bad yeah it's worse he got
from aliens Paxton every movie no you
know you know what I would do this is
the honest truth
kalila leaves I can't escape and we know
now there's demons out there uh-huh
I just take off my clothes and just walk
into the forest or you give up yeah yep
get me you give up okay here's my
question yeah why would you take off all
your clothes you know what I hate that
extra [ __ ] you like no I would just I
don't want my clothes to I want them to
get into me what
I'm yeah I don't want to say it yeah but
that proves my point
from the beginning so I use myself what
what I don't want to say it just no say
it I promise I won't be mad to say
that's stereotypical in silver River so
you just say it's I'm giving up yeah I
give up
it's it's heavy they block the road you
can't communicate with anybody bro I win
that argument
look at my face again I'm sweating my
face again yeah I I would I would
literally do that could possess me now
because I'm not running I'm not doing
the whole rigmarole I'm just trying to
think of some other like really scary
movies that I just I don't know Evil
Dead are used up what do you suppose
that buddy zombie movie guy I'm like 48
days later 28 weeks I love all those 28
days 20 weeks point week lasting to
Busan no I would see now it's a Korean
Zombie one let's go that's DC that I
haven't seen the Delvian zombie I was
decent it was great okay would you like
about it do you have to read what it is
I know it's a closet phobic - it's a
claustrophobic you'll know it's it's
what what what I love about it is that
they're agents on bees you can tell
they're zombies zombies plan eyes what
you're talking about you know they're
just more like you know how they happen
is do this mmm-hmm imagine now what they
would they came out with that so imagine
what they do with their body they walk
weird it's it's it's all you think they
Rea they raised up the bar who those
zombies were [ __ ] weird and and
different than the other zombies they
jump higher the quicker you know man
they're good with the abacus these
zombies are not calculating yeah this is
not going to work yeah they still work
for 10 hours clock in clock now yeah
yeah what's the difference between the
Busan compare compared to 28 days later
like 7c I don't know
I like 28 days later but it's like at
that point so many zombie movies that
come out and I'm not I'm not I'm not
super big little zombie movies because
it's not really scary it's just people
trying to survive and it always ends up
where the human beings are more scary
I'm gonna tell you why I'm up with it
I'm gonna tell you why I know you didn't
see the movie but the Koreans that
aren't zombies trying to survive they
act appropriately not appropriately a
lot like more believable yeah I love
that an example like for instance
they're like um just in terms of the
padding that they would wear they like
wood goat there was like a baseball team
so they took their [ __ ] and patted
themselves up they were like we need to
survive why right they realize they are
smart they realize that if they can't
see you they don't move so they would
take Asian newspapers and and dude and
put water and the newspapers and hide in
the windows you remember they did
different things
he's just cheating and I didn't catch
that my fundamental problem with zombie
movies yeah fundamental problem is how
does ahhm be not know that how do they
know that this person next to him is a
zombie like how do they know like why is
that a thing
because what like if you're standing
next to Tiffany Haddish dude no she's
black that's not the same thing I want
to punch you in your face oh my god no
I'm saying how do dahm bees know that
other zombies are zombies why aren't
they eating I don't know maybe it's like
a smell they give off
yeah but then so then they have if they
had even that little bit of knowledge
like in the walking dead right they're
dead you know like a walking dead right
they then we say that it's about to
smell or now they chop off the hands and
they by the way and they walk around
with other zombies by the way worst
zombie movie ever is the one would Brad
Pitt where he produced dizzy dizzy dizzy
he decided I haven't seen that no he
decided his whole thing was like yeah
there aren't gonna be any violence in a
zombie movie
that's impossible how'd he do that yeah
so you didn't ever see a zombie kill cuz
it was like I want my kids to go this
don't take your kids to see a zombie
movie
yeah okay I just thought that was just
dumb but in that movie they had this
whole stupid thing where they're zombies
knew you were sick right and then also
what he did was when the movie was done
he put his own money into it and put
more scenes and changed things because
it wasn't good it's still not good I
know but imagine what it was like I mean
I need when I'm watching a zombie movie
I want a machete in somebody's [ __ ]
head yeah okay yeah yeah I want that's
why I want to see a lot of blood I need
I need the zombie the zombie kill to
like dramatic [ __ ] that's going on
in the movie ratio that [ __ ] has to be
high for me to enjoy yeah you know so I
just I'm not as I'm not a zombie guy you
know and I do like that I'd like the
frightening ones like if you go on a
date it's good to be like gikas girl to
be like you know like those kind of
wanted yeah in the psychological ones
there's definitely the original the
black and white night of living and dead
dead the reason why that was scary is
because I'd never seen a zombie movie
before that it was black and white you
know and it seemed and they were so slow
and it seemed real you know I love Dawn
of the Dead the original Dawn of the
Dead as well the only the mall yeah the
one in the mall yeah yeah I liked it was
believable to me man with it I see I saw
a remake of that one no no not always
pregnant oh yeah tied her up
the baby came out it was a zombie it's
not the remake it's though it's the one
from the original do you remember that
one yeah but did we made it I know now
that we make up I don't you I can't even
keep track
yeah it's imagine it's like the fighters
forty that they've made so many of them
or like Freddy Krueger
those are good you don't seem to like
those like Halloween I don't like them
you know those happens I don't I don't
like them the first one was pretty
Hellraiser Hellraiser that's [ __ ] no
really I don't know but see that's a
great you know that's gorger's team the
demons yeah yeah yeah here's the one
who's scared of [ __ ] him as a little kid
and I had big brothers from big brothers
of America so I'm like eight years old
and he decided to take me to a double
feature movie and we saw the fog oh
that's she's scared to [ __ ] out it
that's old-school to his fog is okay we
made that one which that's not the mist
right
no it's different but the [ __ ] it was
called the fog and there's like demons
in the fog and the other one was do you
guys remember phantasm because real came
out super such a unique theory phantasm
that's what I remember
but if I look at it now it's stupid but
like at the time I'm a little kid it's
like that [ __ ] was scary so I don't
knows one well you're not gonna grip you
probably never even seen it mm-hmm a
raise your head or yeah I'll tell you
why for David Lynch's for eraser huh
yeah I'll tell you why though have you
seen it it's like once man so long I
need to watch it again it's been a
[ __ ] masterpiece not a masturbate a
nightmare I showed it to Kyle ah yeah
you know David let's yeah yeah you know
I go you watch or his first one into you
as a student when he was me he made it
yeah oh yeah we saw 45 minutes yeah
as she goes she looks at me and she goes
I think went up vomit she goes this is
the worst thing I've ever seen
I hate it but worse than a way because
it may be that baby in it give me that
doll as a yeah I remember that because
it impacted her that might explain the
story because there really is it's so no
story it's like it's literally this guy
it's literally this dude it's literally
the reason why it's atmospheric huh the
movie is atmospheric because black and
white no but what I'm saying is is that
when people are conversing someone who
will ask a question and then the other
person won't respond and there's a forty
second silence and then they'll start
making spaghetti like it's like it's
like weird like unity like it's what a
nightmare is oh right you when you're in
a nightmare it doesn't make any sense
yeah there's something wrong about it I
gotta see that again it's like if you
know why you know it'd be crazy a movie
of a family right just a colorful family
and they're just not responding to each
other they're acting in ways that is
really bizarre you mean like if like
they're at a dinner table and the man
just gets up I'm just making it up right
and he just kind of does a like stands
in the corner upside down I just sit
stance since I've no one said no one
says and he's there for four days yeah
and people go to eat breakfast and he's
still there and meanwhile you know he's
like maybe that he dies and he's
deteriorating right and people and kids
are still playing around and nightmare
yeah it's like a nightmare always right
do you remember this [ __ ] it
nightmare it's a nightmare in another
one that was film kind of like that was
Elephant Man oh that was you know that
to me atmospherically spiracle ii it I
remember as a kid watching it here's one
for you this like I don't wouldn't
necessarily counted as a scary movie but
I think it's scary elements of it is
like seven here's the thing what I
enjoyed about just technique I enjoyed
in the movie yeah you only saw the
aftermath of the killing right so that
made it scary because in your mind to
imagine
fill in the blanks what what got them to
this point and so that's what I really
is not even just that is David Lynch's
not David Lynch um who David Fincher's
interest oh that's aventure dad's
Fincher David Fincher's just his choice
like when the fat man is you know tied
his ankle right and just look you you
could smell that room
right without being there yeah right
just couldn't make it the walls are wet
right
he you see the veins moving great move
see that again it's been a there's a box
and even that one dildo contraption
that's a knife but check it out check it
out that's what I'm talking about but
they only showed like the the blood a
sheet right and you didn't see that
knife till later dry and then that made
you in the movie go oh my god he [ __ ]
her with that he [ __ ] her with a dildo
that was a [ __ ] sword he was forced
to in your mind I've seen them before
the shaky actor when he was being
interviewed yeah so you would you
consider that horror that's what I'm
psychic another one yeah so I don't know
if that's like whatever John wrote that
with yeah yeah yeah cuz I I told the
line on these scary movies of what I
think is like scary because again a
slasher film or like here's an example
like hostile saw like I don't get scared
I just I'm not interested in that's what
I do like oh my god someone's gonna get
their head chopped off and you're
pretending like you don't want to look
and you're like well I'm gonna say one
in there's I forgot yeah Blair Witch the
first Blair Witch Project
[ __ ] them okay what do we mean all right
that was all like that no dude I went to
go see that movie I had a headache you
got vertigo watching that movie cuz it
stupid that was the first lost footage
movie Josh oh no but that's the same
thing
like at the very end that guy's facing
the corner you don't know why people I
had friends of mine you know that [ __ ]
was real and then I said to them oh so
they found them for the MTV Movie Awards
you didn't like no way just cuz I was
sitting huh
it was hype and I was sitting in the
front because it was all sold out yeah
yeah imagine like all that [ __ ] movie
you know yeah you could enjoy what what
the what I liked I liked it the movie
not so much what I liked about it was
the trailer trailer look like it was a
literal bounce for this right it was the
first time they've done like
commercially $10,000 so there's no good
witch horror movies that you like well
you guys like that stupid witch movie
you don't like that oh my god you mean
we you needed subtitles he doesn't like
reading there was no subtitles so they
needed subtitles I don't like how each
is trained to figure out what the [ __ ]
people are talking about alright and
there actually were witches in the
forest so that was that one witch in the
forest and she was cryptic man I know
but what else ears are like the middle
in the end of the movie the people were
right they shouldn't have been it should
have been that they were crazy it turns
out that they would be they just they
needed to be in the [ __ ] force to get
away from me witches I don't know I just
didn't like that but you liked it wasn't
like the the how was filmed I thought it
was lazy the sound was terrible you know
I didn't think it looked that great and
then I just want to hear what's going on
man you know what I'm talking about the
one guy was talking and you were like I
liked the movie yeah but it wasn't a
masterpiece like this [ __ ] said he's
like it's a masterpiece
yes you did I said masterpiece you did I
said I like the movie a lot now what
what about the time what about the
sci-fi ones like aliens love those oh
would that be considered that's just a
great movie yes I think so I think so I
think that but the second one was like
an action movie in sci-fi second one's
more action movie I love
the first one is more horror is a horror
shoot the first one yeah when the when
Ian Ian home that his name yeah no yeah
he played Bilbo Baggins in the first
Aaron looked at up IMDB for sale yes he
at home yeah what yeah okay
Ian home played you see the Lord of the
Rings movies right yeah he played Bilbo
Baggins
mmm-hmm he was though the Android yes
that Android that scared Android was
malfunctioning yeah he was like that was
scary whenever there were time to cat
you knew the cat the casting was very
deems Harry Dean Stan look really like a
[ __ ] a cargo worker will do what not
in frosting the gas thing is the one
that for when when an alien first pop
down the first time god that was just
like I was visceral happening yeah it's
gotta be one of the best movies ever
just went off the rails after that after
aliens - it was just off that was
entertaining though man Winona Ryder who
directed three I don't know she was too
immature
I was terrible do you know why it's her
fault because she was like I'm not gonna
do this anymore and she made herself get
killed and that's why the four story was
so weird do another one but that was
David Fincher's first movie and he got
[ __ ] you know why they fired the
director
and he came in halfway during yeah yeah
hard to miss [ __ ] so he had a rocky
start
didn't like it yeah yeah I didn't like
that one but wanted to were like some of
the math that's the best one or two
after the Godfather 1 & 2
aliens wanted to the sound of movin
wanted to oh yeah yeah just to wrap it
up by talking about the future and let's
talk about Jordan Peele ok yes are you
lied out okay listen this is the
unpopular opinion but I was not a huge
fan of get out only because to me this
is what explain why you spent why I love
the movie the movies like a great but I
to me to me it's like the scarier movie
would be black people taking
over white people like that's the
scarier movie white rich white people
taking over and becoming black I get why
they had to live in the forest okay
because you're not gonna no matter how
much money you have in the real world
you're still gonna be black okay so he's
not gonna get their benefits of being a
rich old white person so I just I don't
know
so for black people which is why he made
the movie and I totally get it's like
this is a horror movie for minorities so
I get that part of it but it was from
mass appeal but they're transferring the
the white brain I mean yeah they were
transferring that into the black body
yeah too as well they needed to be out
there for the experience no no no
they're out there in the forest do
because they don't want they that they
can't live is right right young black
dude is there only a unique story yeah I
do too I mean I here's this new one
coming out us yeah no but is what I do
for me personally what I like in this
it's the same thing of like when you
would which is great for Asian people is
that there were already a lot of really
great Asian made movies yeah that are
like masterpieces yeah you know and but
there isn't a lot of that for black
people there is a Jordans making that
he's going like he's making it like a
horror movie and it's starring black
people that's great that's great it's
just like that's that's that part of it
I love I'm a guy have the defend ordinal
don't you don't have to defend it I'm
just saying I'm just saying let me
restate my point here yeah for mass
appeal for people out there watching
yeah I think that you you really want to
scare why people than you then that's
how you scare you like we were black
people you know why that movie wasn't
for white people I know that's what I'm
saying yeah and I get that right and
that's why I like well found once
because most that's what I like about it
if you think about movies in general
most of them throughout the history of
time are made is made for white peanuts
they're made for minorities that you
have to because imagine all the
storylines that we've seen growing up
we're generally in the point of view of
white people yeah and then as minority
is we have to somehow you know mean
pretend like yeah we get it or whatever
we do because a lot of them has to do
with the human condition and women being
still they have that but in the same way
like if you look at a movie like ET and
you saw that suburban house it's it's
believable the way you know it's messy
and kids running around but that's not
what my house look like yeah we had
[ __ ] octopuses hanging from the rice
cooker rice cooker squid right and so we
have to kind of go it's two things we
have to do when we watch a movie or even
we watched anything like we're watching
friends we just have to imagine like
somehow try to find out is that Jordan
is the voice isn't it great that Jordan
I know and what's great about it is it's
it's bled into other areas like the
spider verse here's a kid he had slag as
moms Puerto Rican I was a great live
I lied oh yeah it was great I went into
that movie you didn't like it for a year
what they will to play that Asian kid in
it for a year I went to Disney and the
six hour session really yeah
and they were even trying to manipulate
my voice to sound younger oh god I'm
sorry man why'd you bring that up
it's a great movie but you're yelling oh
girl he's Kissin he you know he was
considerate of doing maybe a tear oh
that would have been dope he wanted to
do all Asian cast uh-huh and I said I
guess the powers would be like right and
no and I just we need more people like
him yeah more like you know what I have
to say this is something that I that
people don't want to accept in their
brain because because they've somehow
compartmentalized their head that like
when you see Asian like if it's a kung
fu movie yeah like for some reason like
we've conditioned ourselves to be like
well it's that's Asian it's kung fu but
what we don't realize is like the
original Superman was Asian guy you know
who Bruce Lee and no snows type of move
on rila it was one of the first times
you had like well Enter the Dragon
a guy just like normal guy 130 pound
dude like in that way watch these movies
now
for which we'll talk about next time
yeah it's like like the guy from the
raid in those type of movies like that
[ __ ] is what that movie guy is [ __ ]
incredible when you're watching you like
this [ __ ] can yeah this is a
badass dude yeah and what we don't we
there's a disconnect the like when you
put kung fu in something there's a
disconnect between the actor and what
they're doing and that's what Hollywood
trained us to do as opposed to like when
you see like you know Oh John wick you
know it's like it's okay this is just a
white guy doing stuff right yeah
you know except but I think that's
condition I think it is from from the
beginning I saw a trailer for the
original Enter the Dragon okay and and
what they they made the white guy the
star you gotta look it up on YouTube the
original trailer for that movie is Bruce
Lee wasn't the star because they didn't
think of Asian guy can carry a movie
okay Bruce Lee dude yeah now we know
it's Bruce Lee but at the time they
didn't realize what a mega star he was
gonna be so much man yeah just but it's
like we have to like accept so I really
would I wish he would have done that
well I think we're there now I think
we're there now they just need more
voices yeah I just thought about a good
idea then just hear me out on this for
well podcast no a movie of we do the
mega podcast me you Theo von bryan
callen right D'Elia everyone you know
cabin and then it turns into a zombie
movie
and not in time you but it's some sort
of horror movie I like it we're doing a
podcast yeah yeah you don't have to die
first
yeah yeah the band what Joe Rogan yeah
all right that was that fun are you
satisfied with satisfy yeah see we're
gonna continue to do this oh we gonna do
this month Lana do we're gonna try to do
it monthly and we're gonna make it more
bigger than this but right now huh how
long was this I'm Aaron where we at
our 24 beautiful past an hour look at
that I thought I fizzled out at the end
yeah kind of laughs I'm gonna cut out
some things know some dead space yeah I
said a couple of things that weren't
good yeah we're gonna cut those things
out all right I got to cut this out
talking about the things we're gonna cut
out all right so and guys think we end
it can we as a collective come up with a
name if we continue to do gonna continue
to do it great job we'll be our own
thing yeah yeah it's gonna be called you
know we're thinking about we're gonna do
a thing a monthly thing the three of the
three of us right and you want to go
racial on it I don't think we should
racial yeah
I never well Erik G and Julie was cool
but we will come up with a different one
do you like that
no it's think of something will come up
with it you know it's like don't make it
racial though you know let's just do it
like a jewelry making Goonies but ik
only goo keys okay okay okay
this is a tiger belly my brother has a
potty we do know Stevie we be
youtube.com slash DB we BST ee b ee w ee
b ee okay i'll put it on the screen
yeah well can you put a I'm gonna put it
on the screen in the description yes
it'll be in the description and then
target belly it isn't my good buddy
Bobby Lee these actually are two my
favorite people in the whole wide world
nobody catch like this unless you love
each other did we fight we just have a a
it's fine
you know people learn and then that was
that so next time but we're probably
gonna discuss kung fu movies and you
know send us messages and buy movies
that you think you want us to talk about
and we're gonna do this regularly like I
said once a month at least for now until
we make it big it's gonna be big y'all
but anyway this has been riffing with
Griffin thank you for listening and I'll
see you next time
[Music]